radical right-wing radio host rush
limbaugh
in many ways the father of modern
right-wing political media in in
uh we could say that actually in a
number of different ways
has died at the age of 70
from lung cancer which we learned about
a year ago
that he had you may recall that
shortly after his diagnosis donald trump
awarded him the presidential medal of
freedom during the state of the union
address
in the year 2020 he has died
and this has brought out it's really
brought out
the worst of many people but also
understandable
ire and in a sense relief that rush
limbaugh will no longer be
on the american airwaves and i've
received
so many emails about this some people
gleeful
at the death of rush limbaugh others
more circumspect and i want to be
sort of super clear i don't believe in
participating
in cheering people's illness or death
nor do i ever wish illness or death upon
anyone and
at the same time as adults most of us
we can recognize that some people have a
positive influence in the world
and some people have a negative
influence in the world and rush
limbaugh's influence on the world
was disgustingly and decidedly and
unquestionably
negative and disastrously so rush
limbaugh used to do a segment
where he would celebrate when people
with aids died
as written by mary strom larson quote he
garnered
a following with outrageous programming
that includes such features as
celebratory moments
when another aids victim died which he
called aids
updates that is disgusting
it knows no bounds that is that is the
lower than anything
he regularly referred to
women who i guess believe in women's
rights as feminine nazis
he regularly took
pleasure in the death of people on the
left here he is
rush limbaugh gleeful at the death of
former supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg just ecstatic at the
possibility that it presents
for the right to further take over the
supreme court
washington post has a story today
democrats
largely powerless to stop the gop
from confirming their court choice folks
do you know how big this is
this is huge this could be
i want to whisper this the end of roe
versus wade but but
this is going to have a
massive impact on the american judiciary
it's thus going to have a massive
impact on american culture and society
so this is absolutely and endlessly
disgusting so
listen i've been seeing the post i've
been getting the messages i've been
seeing the tweets of people
essentially doing a dance on rush
limbaugh's grave that that's not in my
constitution to do that just doesn't
feel right and so
i don't do it uh when rush limbaugh was
diagnosed with lung cancer i didn't
cheer
rush limbaugh has a family i don't know
if he has kids i guess maybe he does i
mean listen
he he's a terrible he was a terrible
person
but illness and death affect people and
i i would never wish that on anyone but
there is no doubt that we can recognize
this person was an absolutely terrible
influence on american politics
he was responsible for
much of the um not just you know
coarsening of language is sort of like
okay coarsening of language
but the normalization of a certain type
of gutter sniping
politics during his early days on radio
and uh the world was um
what was negatively affected by his
presence on the airwaves so rush
limbaugh dead at 70.
uh and those are my thoughts and quite
frankly i don't i don't feel the need to
say too much more about it
but i do want to talk a little bit uh
about donald trump's
bizarre rambling self-centered eulogy
for rush on fox news if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video